now kirsten and christian we are on the
scene of this breaking news situation we
did just hear a briefing the latest from
metro police what i can tell you right
now a security guard was shot by a
person inside this casino we're told
that security guard was shot multiple
times but is at the hospital and is
stable now that person the suspect in
this situation was detained according to
police no word on the charges he will
face at this time now we did ask if
there was any lockdown in the casino
anything like that the officer said at
this time it is pretty much business as
usual the hotel he said handled this
situation pretty well and no one else
was reported hurt now again a security
guard shot multiple times by someone
else inside santa fe station here that
security guard is stable at the moment
this is still a developing situation you
can see still a pretty big police
presence in this area but again the
casino is still operating hotel is still
operating make sure to stay with eight
news now for the very latest as this
continues to develop both on air and
online we will have another update for
you at 4 30 and at five o'clock
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now